مليون مستخدم في اول خمسه ايام الحديث عن
حضره في المدارس والجامعات وتهديدها
لعشرات المهن الى ادراجه في عدد من
المصالح الحكوميه هذا ملخص اربعه اشهر من
روبوت الدردشه الاشهر
بعد اطلاقه في نوفمبر الماضي ميرا مراتي
مديره تكنولوجيا التنفيذي في منصه open اي
وهي المصممه لتشاجي بيتي تعتقد ان الذكاء
الاصطناعي يجب تنظيمه في حديث ياما مجله
تايم تقول بصراحه ان الاداه يمكن ان تختلق
حقائق او معلومات لكنها تقارن طريقه عمله
باي محادثه طبيعيه مع البشر مراتي تعتقد
بضروره تدخل الجهات التنظيميه والحكومات
والفلاسفه وعلماء الاجتماع وحتى الفنانين
واي شخص يمكن ان يساعد في تنظيم ادوات
الذكاء الاصطناعي
لديه ذكاء اصطناعي ويتحكم بانظمه المركبه
الفضائيه اما اغنيتها المفضله فهي
بارانويد اندرويد التي انتجت في
التسعينيات وتصور حياه البشر في القرض 21
بطريقه
سوداويه حيث الانفصال عن المجتمع والتوحد
مع التكنولوجيا على حساب التفاعل البشري
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ومعنا هنا في الاستوديو الرئيسي التنفيذي
لمؤسسه صحافه الذكاء الاصطناعي محمد عبد
الظاهر اهلا بك يا محمد معنا في صباح
العربيه ويسعدها الصباح مجددا محمد ميرا
مراتي احد ابرز مطورين شات تتحدث عن ضروره
تنظيم هذه التقنيه لتطوير واستخدام الذكاء
الاصطناعي اليوم هل يجب على الحكومات
حكومات الدول ان تتكفل بهذه المساله
وبالتالي تضبط الوضع ام يمكن فعلا لتقنيه
ومطوريه هذه التقنيه ان يعملوا شروطا
معينه وبحدود لاستخدامات هي المشكله ليست
في
تطبيق لكن هي مشكله في تطبيقات الذكاء
الصناعي جميعا يعني يمكن الكلام ده يمكن
اليونسكو بتنادي به من اكثر من ست سبع
سنين يجب وضع تشريعات تنظيميه لتقنيات
الذكاء الاصطناعي يعني مثلا في ضمن
الاشياء مثلا في فرنسا كان في بعض
الكاميرات اللي هي بتصور الوجه في محطات
قطار تعتمد على الذكاء الاصطناعي تم هي
نسبه الخطا فيها 30 35% وقدت اتهامات
افراد كثيره بالارهاب وبالقلق ونتيجه ان
هي بتقرا تعبيرات وجه خاطئه او دلالاتها
ليست بالصحيحه لما نتطرق الى
العالم منذ ظهور النسخه واحد اتنين تلاته
5 لحتى استشرافا للنسخه اربعه التي بدات
الديمو دلوقتي في مش تو تجاوزات ولكن هناك
اعتماد كبير من الباحثين والمطورين عليه
في في الحديث في الحصول على العديد من
المعلومات التي التي قد تؤدي فعلا الى
معلومات مضلله في بعض الاحيان طيب استاذ
محمد خلينا قبل ما نحكي للنسخه الاخيره
حتى هذه الفتره اليوم ما سر بان يكون هذا
التطبيق هو الاسرع نموا وانتشارا في
العالم يعني احنا بنتحدث عن ايام قليله
وصل ل 100 مليون مستخدم يعني بعد شهرين
فقط اذا ما قررناه مثلا
لقب قديم هي حاليا تقريبا ما يعادل 15 15
مليون مستخدم تخيلي انه عنده مليون مستخدم
يوميا
دلوقتي الاستثمارات بتاعته يمكن
مايكروسوفت حطت تقريبا 10 مليار في
استثمارات تانيه يمكن استثمارات 25 مليار
خلال العام الحان احنا
اكثر سرعه اكثر براعه بيبتدي يحطه دخله
فيه جرافيكس بتاخده في تصميمات تانيه
ابتدى كمان يعمل تحديثات الاخطاء السابقه
معلومات ووقفت لحد 21 لا تبقى تحديثات بل
هيدوق جزء استشراف اقول له مثلا الاقتصادي
مثلا في منطقه الكاريبي بناء على معطيات
بناء على تحليل بيانات ضخمه كبيره جدا في
مجالات مختلفه طيب بالنسبه للغات لانه
مثلا تشاد جي بي تك
الوسخات القديمه فيها العربي او بعض
اللغات ولكن لكن احد المعضلات التي تم حل
كثير منها في الشات بيتي فور اعتماده على
تحليل اللغات ومعالجه اللغات الطبيعيه
بطريقه مذهله
فانا اتوقع هيكون هو محرك البحث الرئيسي
بعد استحواذ مايكروسوفت عليه وبدقه في
وضعه كل منتجات وتطبيقات وبرامج
مايكروسوفت هيكون هو محرك البحث الرئيسي
خلال الفتره القادمه طيب استاذ محمد اين
يمكن ان نستفيد من تشاد جي بي تي ليخدمن
كبشر ولكن لا يكون خطر على وظائفنا وعلينا
في مهنا
استخدامه انا من رايي يجب ان هناك يكون
تدقيق كامل في كافه المعلومات لاني عباره
عن خروجات معينه
عشرات من الروبوتس اللي بتجاوبك مجرد
اختلاف الحرف الواحد مجرد اختلاف كلمه في
السؤال بتعطيك نتائج مختلفه تماما فهنا
يجب ان يكون هناك ضبط في استخدامه في انا
من رايي في مجال الاكاديمي لك كدكتور
اكاديمي كباحث اكاديمي لا يمكن اعتماد
عليه في كثير من المعلومات لانها ليست
موثقه او ليست اكاديميه بحثا لانه يعتمد
على الاف من المواقع والاف من عنده قد
تكون معلومات موضه بالمدارس مثلا يعتمدوا
عليه بعض الطلبه وحتى في الجامعات حتى
امريكا اجتاز بكريوس الحقوق واجتاز
ماجستير في في
تخصص معين من الطب في كريديشن كتير
بالنسبه له اكيد للحديث تتمه ودائما في
المستقبل راح يصير للمزيد من التطورات
فيما يتعلق بهذا التطبيق الاسرع نموا
وانتشارا في العالم اليوم رئيسه التنفيذي
المؤسسه صحافه الذكاء الاصطناعي محمد عبد
الظاهر شكرا